[Music]
I don't wanna fight no more I Only Wanna
Get Too Short maybe don't slam that door
tonight
and then another off the tracks that's
time we can't get back we can say
tomorrow if we try
whoa
whoa to make this right oh
[Music]
I want
you I want me and I want peace
said everybody needs a place somewhere
that's warm and safe for shelter from
this crazy world room
but tonight I let the rain inside I took
away your place to hide I'm sorry that I
made you cry again
oh
you know that we can make it right oh
kiss me good night cause I just wanna
make you laugh
I just wanna see that smile babe we're
only here for a little while and I just
want to hold you till you fall asleep
cause I want love I want us I want you I
want me and I want peace
[Music]
and I need it right now
you don't have to fight
kiss me all night
[Music]
I want us upon you I want me and I want
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you